mikolaiv has been without running water
for a week
[Music]
now another russian missile means some
homes will also lose electricity
the war damage to ukraine's
infrastructure is estimated to have
already cost 100 billion dollars
but the human toll of this persistent
shelling is incalculable
well incredibly only one person was
injured in this strike but there are
currently nearly 300 people being
treated in nikolai's hospitals due to
wounds caused by russian attacks and
many people have had enough they don't
want to roll the dice anymore and have
decided to leave
that decision is not easy
but every day more people here make it
we are leaving
because it's getting more dangerous here
one time we got shelled it's very hard
to survive here with our kids
in the district we are living in we can
hear echoes of active fighting
unfortunately we decided to leave
alongside russia's push in the east they
are also building up troops on the
western front in the south and are
expected to push along the coast into
mikaelaev one family here has just fled
a russian occupied area
there's russians there now
there are shellings every day
they're going house to house that's why
we took our children and decided to move
to a safer place
they take what they can but leave so
much behind
see it's all women and children look at
them they didn't do nothing wrong
they didn't harm anyone they need to
leave their country their homes their
families their fathers
their husbands their brothers
and while women and children leave their
husbands and sons are often on or
preparing to go to the front line
today there were many explosions near
our district and that's when we finally
decided to leave
plus my husband is going to defend the
country
and her husband as well
this is like no other goodbye
many don't know how far they're going or
for how long
or what will be here for them
if they ever come back
jason farrell sky news nick alive